is mayonnaise and instrument by
mysterion I don't get it hey guys I love
interacting with you so I thought I'd
make a monthly segment where I jump into
the comments read the best ones have a
few laughs
but also answer your medical questions
I'm gonna get right into it and here we
kiss bullish geez little fish cranker
I need a a Quay asks is water wet Anita
water is inherently wet that's how wet
is defined in my opinion weird questions
Sara Ashby is it safe to crack your own
neck I heard that it's bad but it feels
super good cracking your neck is
probably not a bad thing as long as
you're not doing some crazy techniques
on yourself just the same way that
cracking knuckles doesn't cause
arthritis this has been proven time and
time again all that is our nitrogen air
bubbles escaping from your joint space
nothing dangerous is happening a dtt can
you read and write Russian I can read
Russian probably at a first grade level
don't judge me I came here when I was
five and I didn't get much training
afterwards but I can't write Russian
Casey sweet
do you know heretic Russian Bollywood
actor you act and look like him I don't
know who that is but do I really look
like him this guy no way
thoughts on the tide pod epidemic have
you had patients coming in having
consumed them Tessa I have not had
patients coming in who have consumed
them I don't understand who's doing this
it goes without saying that Tide Pods
are harmful just like I don't go around
explaining and lecturing people that
staples are not good to eat can you
create a video on decreasing fat around
the abdominal area for men hashtag gym
struggles Anthony I'm with you a lot of
my patients are with you it's very hard
to lose abdominal fat but the one thing
we have to keep in mind is you cannot
spot reduce you have to work on
decreasing your entire body's fat
composition in order to see improvements
in your abdominal area time for a
haircut doc I agree look I got one what
was your undergraduate degree well Kent
I did one of those seven-year combine
programs where
bachelor's in science which was of life
sciences and then a doctorate of
osteopathic medicine so it's a BS do
degree seven years combined only did
three years of undergraduate studies and
four years of med school how often
should you get a check-up well Alexi it
really depends on not only your age
group it depends on your sex
it depends what medical conditions you
have but I think it's a safe bet to say
that you should at least see your doctor
every year to have a healthy
conversation and figure out when you
should return is it good if someone
poops after every meal well first of all
Poonam everybody poops it's a good book
you should check it out
after every meal it sounds excessive but
if it's normal for you that's what
you've been doing your whole life it
shouldn't be a problem if everything
else is fine Mandy Kay did you cut your
lip or is that a cold sore I know what
video the alcohol verse exercise video
and yes that is a healing cold sore is a
herpes virus
I took valtrex and went away by the way
a lot of you don't know this if you have
an active herpes outbreak you could ask
your doctor to write your prescription
for valtrex he'll shortened lifespan of
your cold sore 1 1 5 4 clean what about
sex versus exercise I volunteer as
tribute as long as I get dr. Mike what
about sex versus exercise sex can be
exercised but you burn only about a
hundred calories having sex and I love
that radioactive food wrote that they're
in for threesome Thanks radioactive food
I don't know what your user name means
what's owed Kate ran there is research
that said smoking can prevent us from
Alzheimers is it true can you discuss
about the pros and cons of cigarette at
your and your recommendation my
recommendation here is clear don't smoke
there are no health benefits whoever
told you that smoking prevents
Alzheimer's disease is probably saying
that because you died earlier when you
smoked so you never get a chance to
develop Alzheimer's disease how do I
fall asleep faster and how do I stay
asleep well address it depends that I
would need to ask you a lot more
questions but one of the biggest things
that I see people mess up when it comes
to their sleep is having their phone by
their side phones are a distraction
because you tend to look at them and see
that your friends are up to some cool
stuff and you get jealous or maybe you
read a work email and you get anxious
and all that anxiety and FOMO is
horrible for your sleep but the blue
light that your phone emits
also hurts the melatonin sleep hormone
in your brain which may not hurt how
fast you fall asleep but it hurts the
quality of your sleep for sure that's
been documented and next look at your
sleep environment make sure it's cool in
your room make sure it's dark in your
room and quiet in your room and by quiet
doesn't mean completely silent it just
means that if you have a noise make sure
it's not like make sure it's like a
white noise that stays constant is there
any medical reason for the legal
drinking age obviously kids shouldn't be
downing bottles at 5:00 but what's
significant from say 18 to 21 Andrew I
think the reason that the United States
the legal drinking age is 21 has a lot
to do with the religious nature of the
people that move to the United States
from England but I also think that the
later you start drinking the better it
is for your mind because even at 18 or
21 your mind is still developing W
Rivera
wow this was annoying very I don't know
what video you talking about man Marissa
Buscemi I would love to hear your
thoughts on soy products and whether it
increases risk for cancer especially
breast cancer
Marissa great question soy has
phytoestrogens in it phytoestrogens are
basically the plant form of the natural
estrogen that you find in your own body
your body can react to these
phytoestrogens and if you're predisposed
to developing a cancer specifically a
breast cancer that's estrogen sensitive
eating a lot of soy products are having
a high soy diet can speed up the rate of
you getting this cancer and can make it
worse we don't have any answers or exact
answers on what everybody should eat but
I think keeping it in moderation being
smart and not overeating soy products is
smart it's like a through dry road you I
saw a ps4 controllers in the background
of a few year video 'he's very
perceptive
what games do you play i play on
playstation 4 call of duty world war 2
and i play overwatch if you want to add
me my username is real doctor might add
maple plain assume ER a booster how do
you exercise i have an interesting
exercise routine because i do all sorts
of different things i like to keep it
varied so i'll play soccer i'll play
basketball go boxing but also lift
weights i'm a big fan of head
be weightlifting to make sure that I
stay strong that's very important to me
and we've seen that you the best results
come from those who wait train and
cardio train so I always like to mix up
both of those routines dr. Mike I have a
question for you that's why we're doing
this why do I faint after blood exam the
sight of blood doesn't bother me and I'm
not afraid of needles Tyra it sounds
like what you're having is called a
vasovagal response you without even
thinking about it your primitive brain
has a startling response to getting
poked and losing some blood it's not
your frontal part of your brain which
makes some of you are more complicated
decisions for you but your primitive
brain starts panicking that it saw blood
that you're losing blood your heart rate
drops your blood pressure and you don't
get enough blood flow to the brain and
when that happens you faint or you feel
like your guns at faint and you're gonna
black out now much you can do with that
what about it but be cautious of
standing up afterwards know that it
could happen and take the proper
precautions I couldn't help but notice
the pits wet you really should look into
Thompson T's they changed my life
chance I don't know what Thomson tees
are but I often wear scrubs so I don't
know if I can wear Thompson's tees what
I will say is that my armpits do sweat a
lot and I am considering getting Botox
injections into my armpits it's that
serious and that may be a future YouTube
video
stay tuned sana Fatima can you please
make a video on CT scans MRIs
ultrasounds are they really that
dangerous to get can a CT scan actually
lead to cancer MRI scans and ultrasounds
are relatively benign sana so you don't
have to worry about that CT scans do
pose a health risk because they do
expose you expose you to unnecessary
radiation how much of that radiation
actually leads to cancer is a topic
that's up for debate I have talked to
some radiologists who believe that the
risk is overstated because they believe
that the type of radiation that you get
from CT scans is not the same type of
radiation that we've studied from
Hiroshima and other times when we use
nuclear weapons because that's what we
use as our basis of what is acceptable
level of radiation for the human body to
accept without health risks if you don't
need a CT
don't get it if there's a significant
health benefit for you getting a CT scan
like figuring out whether or not you
have appendicitis and you need emergency
surgery yes get the CT scan but if your
stomach hurts you just want to figure
out what's going on maybe it's better to
hang out a day or two and see if the
stomach pain goes away and not get a CT
scan follow my logic there s so
muhammad' what is your opinion about
meditation I love a meditation I think
we live in a crazy stressful world where
chronic stress is all around us and our
bodies are not meant to handle chronic
stress we can handle individual stresses
on a short-term but chronic stress is
horrible and meditation is a great way
to break out of chronic stress what does
the future of medicine look like a lot
of individual personalized health care
meaning that based on your genetics
we're gonna give you a specific
treatment for example I could have two
patients come in with the same illness
but treat them totally different based
on their genetics and I think that's
totally awesome I also think there's
gonna be an increase in telemedicine
which is basically like skyping your
doctor and I think that has a use
granted limited use but there's
definitely a place to medicine where we
can use that in the more technologically
savvy we all become the more we can use
that sort of technology to make us
healthier hey Doc you are losing your
charm anyways nothing in this world is
permanent hope I'm not losing my charm
man bean this person isn't even have a
username within the exercise category
which would you consider the most
beneficial for long-term health I'm a
huge fan of hit hit for the win it helps
your resting heart rate it helps with
heart rate variability it's good on your
insulin levels and it's good for fat
distribution so I'm a fan of hit I swear
by hit I practice hit I reccomend hit
how many more times can I say hit before
you understand that I love hit hit all
righty I hope you enjoyed the first
installment of this new series go and
watch some more YouTube videos of mine
leave some comments because I'm gonna be
looking at the recent comments and
answering them in an upcoming video as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]